so hear me out we've had steak we've had
pasta hot dog what better way to end
this season then to finish it off with
cake
what is this jacket
the cutoff trench coat so cake or not
what's going on how many jackets CEOs
for our season finale the food above all
food or that you eat at the end of other
foods and that is pants what
Mincy no it's cake we are going to eat
three cakes in three days at three
drastically different price points to
find out which one is the most worth it
at its given price point
I love cake cake represents celebration
it represents happiness the symbol of
joy and coming together I'm not crazy
about cake honestly I think most cake
it's just too sweet it's one note I'm
not saying
hate is bad I want to have some honestly
good pick today and I have that for you
we'll do that for you wonder which one
of these is going to take the cake hey
that's pretty good
[Music]
my name is Betty Porto one of the owners
of portals my green cafe my sister
Margaretta I work together who was was
started by my mother we came from Cuba's
immigrants started making cakes at home
and selling them to their neighbors for
whatever they could give her people to
bring other people feeling each other's
a lady and server like and sons that
makes incredible cakes and the rest is
just hard work and how many cakes are
you doing these days oh my god we go 200
skin we have maybe 15 or 16 case that we
make on a regular basis every day Hines
up kids yes and the ones that we're
gonna be showcasing uses their milk
Ameri so yeah tell us about the recipe
it's a tres leches so we take the turf
like a sponge which is a sponge that's
soaked in milk syrup and then we filled
it with whipped cream and fresh berries
we tried all kinds of different fillings
and this was the one that everybody
likes the most
and ever since we put it out it's only
been growing and growing it's our number
one best song I think because they has
the sweetness of the is ledger which is
the conveys no but then the torque
berries are we ended up using kind of
cut it down so there's a balance when I
first heard about Porto's I ask somebody
where should I go to eat they told me
about the potato balls
cheese roll yes I know we're not eating
though today we why not we gave you all
the way low we're gonna get that's a guy
okay we have now been presented with the
famous token various take it is a tres
Lake a cake stuffed with berries it's a
beautiful thing I think first we take a
sip of the Ordos quarter dates are two
shots of espresso with condensed milk
and milk in it and in this heart
represents the love that I have for at
all Cheers
oh I love the condensed milk in there if
you don't like the bitter taste of
coffee this is perfect for you
it still has a nice balance of
bitterness it's there this will teach
you how to like talk that this cake I
can only tell them to like this cake off
the bat I mean it's very pretty it's
pretty but it's like still very natural
you know my big complaint is when cakes
are like a neon yellow oh this looks
like I want to be my mouth right now
so the underside that was on the plate
is just so moist moist is a word we're
going to be saying a lot in this episode
it's the best use of a not great word
this game is very good look how it stays
here for tres leches cake it's all about
being saturated with that syrup dense
with moisture the creaminess that the
sponge becomes is different than the
creaminess of the whipped cream and then
you bite into a berry and that's
actually the hardest texture but then it
explodes with more moisture in your
mouth they should rename it three
moistures my favorite part of this cake
how it feels like I'm drinking the most
satisfying glass of milk you would think
that a cake milk doesn't taste good
you'd be wrong I mean the bar has been
set very I let's get out of here
pretty good cake right guys they gave us
sandwiches mmm
tres leches milk and berries cake $27
it's a cake you can take home to your
mother
my mother works have any cake she loves
my back field he also got some potato
balls cake that I love okay we did it
one quick video quick hit me with a
moist cake sir did you know that German
chocolate cake was not invited by the
Germans who's invented by an Englishman
laughs in German is just confusing you
better kick oh what'd you name it
no Nicky cake I could name it ol nasty
all right so see you tomorrow yes please
just pop it in shove it in there
where we go tomorrow my name is Darby
Jocko I'm the pastry chef here at proof
bakery and today we're going to serve
you an espresso chocolate cake so walk
us through that process boarding that
cake first off we make the devil's food
cake sort rim of broken down into three
layers first layer so it's basically a
little espresso sugar water commit which
is a creamy pudding we cook ours a
little bit further than normal we take
it almost to the breaking point so it's
really thick because we actually use it
as a nice thing as well that's kind of
really thick this is the espresso
buttercream and then just build again
repeat the whole process and then we
crumb coat it which basically protects
the whole cake so when you iced it none
of the crumbs fall out and then glaze
them right before they go out to the
store save all the scraps that we cut
off the cakes actually just get baked
dried out and then we grind those or the
crumbs that go on the side of the cake
pretty much our biggest seller here
besides our croissants it's not overly
sweet it's not overly powerful with the
espresso just balanced and we serve it
at room temp otherwise the flavors get
muddled in the cold I think he needs to
have all the flavors kind of brighten up
when they're room temperature do you
have a favorite cake I mean this is
press okay kai eat my birthday yeah
that's a good measure yeah never Casey
we through have a cake that I meet a
girl yeah can't go wrong let's start
with our cappuccinos cappuccino
cappuccino cappuccino ah delightful
powerful you would become very easily
addicted to dress yes this whole thing
is so satisfying to look at I also
really like when she used the blowtorch
tonight it elects this little Ridge of
melted
at the seam of every slice I find that
very satisfying oh yeah you left-handed
yes that's why setting the left side the
cake improve
[Music]
here we go oh no you just try that with
me
outstanding incredible what word am I
looking for right now let me the best
cake I've ever had in my life
it's room-temperature cake that's the
difference I think it's room temperature
it's alive in my mouth it's not too
sweet but it's perfectly sweet it
doesn't fall apart it's not too crummy
everything is like in perfect order a
structural integrity level that means
the textures are balanced I can do this
I can make my points with the cake okay
that's a tight two you know that's what
I like not too much going on but
everything that is going on going on
good I'm gonna say it
this cake wins you haven't even seen a
lot of cake yet I'm just gonna have
truffles on it Adam okay
leave those quest oh I'm driving respect
the quest own ah look at those flaky
layers doh look at that yeah
so what do you think about proof I mean
the proof is in the front room you know
did the promoter neutral curmudgeon or
pretty girl babycakes should be same I
want to be like that can I go take back
three kick back kick back did you know
that
FDR's favorite cake was fruitcake also
my favorite my favorite cake is carrot
cake did you know Bill Clinton's
favorite cake is carrot cake cake is
delightful I thought he's not proof yeah
I was having a good time three cakes
three days to the last pot Bottega Louie
who cakes down one to go
I had cake for breakfast I'm not doing
too hot
[Music]
James Rozelle I'm the cake designer here
at will take a Louie and we produce
custom cakes anything you want we can
certainly create anything tell us a
little more about Bottega Louie what
kind of place is bad
so we'll take a looook was founded in
2007 have a restaurant and marketplace
so restaurant specializes in Italian
fare type cuisine while the marketplace
is where you can come in get some
pastries whether it's macaroons beignets
chocolates we produce over 14,000
macaroons a day a day
yes macaroons are probably our most
popular sweet item here we're getting
those and so we're going to be eating
the cake tell us a bit about your
process so if you want a cake from
Bottega Louie and you'll sit down eat
cake discuss details have some coffee
maybe some champagne and during the
consultation you get to taste 10
varieties of fillings along with our
chocolate and vanilla cakes so Stephens
already done all this yes it's already
happy yeah you guys are already best
friends yes we are I'm the one out of
the boots and then we'll go into baking
the cake once that sketch has been
approved by the client
so we bake cakes while them to cool
during that process we'll be making all
the before whether it's sugar flowers
ribbons bows lace everything is done out
of an edible media once all of the
decorative aspects are completed the
cake is filled and iced and staffed then
at that point we just put it all
together your cake I firmly believe has
to taste as good as it looked so our
cakes start at 9 dollars per person and
they can go up depending on how
intricate and detailed the design so the
final price type for your cake turns out
to be 1,001
that is the most expensive food we've
eaten on this show to date and what does
cake symbolize for you cake just
symbolizes life celebration for me when
I think about cake puts a smile on my
face
and I think that's how it should be for
everyone else this is a I've never seen
a cake like this it is very satisfying
to look at it in case you were wondering
where the cake is a box okay the box is
the cake yeah I guess that see what's
inside what mysteries it holds Wow art
right here
I love how perfectly square it
everything is - worth it so what kind of
cake did you select for us this is
partially your yes your ideas what I
told him was make it fun exciting I told
him that you are very hard to please
which is relative to you you're very
easy to please
I'm a happy person is that okay it's
fine let's go to the cake the gift box
cake the funfetti strawberry buttercream
and white chocolate buttercream with a
flavor explosion the end I can't wait to
eat everything on his box we've got 80
people worth of kid and we're sharing a
slice I love that it's not just an
object sitting there it's like a still
life of a scene
[Music]
[Applause]
draw Barry dolor he's like a delicious
strawberry shortcake with sprinkles
take me back to my childhood
ten-year-old Stephen would have went ham
on this cake the imagine ten year old
Stephen though I'm just imagining a
smaller version of you hmm
I'm getting that sugar rush right now
yeah I'm getting that sugar rush right
now to the strawberry is a very fresh
strawberry place it's like I'm sucking
them right out of the peel the seeds on
the cake the candy churn oh hi Karen
let me like a little chocolate whopper I
want you to break it off like a wishbone
oh cool give it wish sure all right
what was your wish didn't come true
it's like decoration it's fun to eat
something that's shaped like this it's
like a dried pasta noodle that's sweet
whoa I'm eating it tastes like paper I
call the party hat do you want to wear
it
Party Time
this is the most fun just eating
whatever I want to eat and having no
consequences except for the massive
sugar rush from having disclaimer there
are not no consequences to eating a lot
of cake this cake is delicious but it is
very clearly a cake inspired by your
coming more two kinds of green eight
layers sprinkles in there as well other
kind of sugar bobbles everywhere it's
like the lucid dream
Stephen gates
like that it's good KK with my Canadian
the final question does it taste as good
as it look I would say better I would
say I think I'm incapable of eating any
more all right let's get out of here oh
my heart is ready Cheers which one was
the most worthy at its price let me
break it down we're take a Louie amazing
I've never seen a cake like that in my
life
overall though proof was the most worth
it was a perfect cake in the way that
you actually had cake when you're a
little kid we spent over a thousand
dollars on a cake at Bodega I truly love
what they got the experience James all
that being said this is the hardest one
my word the winner goes to
Porto's they bust out thousands of those
cakes and each one is the same amazing
quality we have one more task now we
must deliver this to the taste
headquarters so you guys ready
[Music]
you
[Music]
oh yes
[Music]